quand une nouvelle espèce envahissante
de surcroît arrive dans un écosystème
c'est important de comprendre le rôle
qu'elle va jouer dans la chaîne
alimentaire
justement une jeune chercheuse se
passionne pour le gobie à taches noires
un petit poisson prédateur vorace
arrivé au canada il y a trente ans
alors le gobi est arrivé en 1990 dans la
rivière saint clair puis apprécier fait
son chemin au niveau des grands lacs
puis dans les années 2000 on l'a
retrouvé dans le fleuve saint laurent
j'ai choisi d'étudier le gobie pas c'est
une espèce envahissante c'est vraiment
un des menaces les plus importantes
envers les écosystèmes aquatiques
déjà petit j'étais tout le temps dans
l'eau mon père aimait tant moins initiés
à la pêche très très jeune puis j'ai
vécu sur le lac saint-françois toute ma
jeunesse et mon adolescence et j'ai
observé l'arrivée du gobi donc c'est fou
de penser que comme retourner aux
sources puis je peux dire que maintenant
je fais la recherche dans ma cour
arrière
dame en question
[Musique]
le gobie à taches noires est une espèce
envahissante
originaire d'asie de la mer caspienne et
de la mer noire ce petit poisson se
serait introduit en amérique du nord par
les autres ballast des bateaux provenant
d'europe c'est auxerre va ajuster le
poids des navires et à les stabiliser
lors de grandes traversées mais de
nombreux organismes s'y retrouve et sont
relâchés à leur arrivée dans un nouvel
environnement
on peut facilement reconnaître les
gobelets taches noires par leurs tâches
noires sur la nageoire dorsale puis
aussi que ce qui est typique du gobi
sait qu'il va avoir les yeux sur le
dessus de la tête je trouve ça sent le
printemps une grenouille ton visage les
gabiers attachement leur particularité
c'est que l'argent qu'elle vienne ici
forme une vente hausse non c'est un
mécanisme qui a favorisé leur leur
établissement puis la propagation dans
les habitants parce qu'ils peuvent
s'accrocher à toi des roches ou même
dans les bateaux de cargaisons ayons pu
s'accrocher avec 512 là
l'étudiante chercheuse veut connaître la
place d'hugo biya tache noire dans la
chaîne alimentaire du saint-laurent pour
comprendre s'il est néfaste ou non pour
les espèces indigènes c'est un poisson
très féroces agressifs territoria donc
ils vont manger compétitionner avec les
espèces natives de la région et va aussi
avoir la prédation sur soi les neuf
d'espèces de poissons ou soli ressources
alimentaires que d'autres espèces
natives de la région pourraient manger
aussi
le gobie à taches noires et manger à son
tour par des prédateurs indigènes comme
l'achigan la perchaude le brochet ou le
doré mais depuis qu'on retrouve ce gobbi
dans les eaux du saint-laurent l'achigan
et le brochet ont grossi est sur le
point de départ des recherches de
christina charrette
j'essaie de comprendre si le gobie
représente une proie nutritives pour ses
poissons le ou non c'est ce que le gobi
et du fast food ou est-ce que le gorille
des bons nutriments mais ça favorise
vraiment la croissance des poissons
comme chaque été depuis trois ans
christina et son équipe du river
institute sillonnent le fleuve en bateau
pour pêcher des gobies mais aussi ses
poissons prédateurs et ses proches
alors ce matin et on voit directement
les maîtres les filets maillants pour
aller récolter les afghans et les
perchaudes par un site on vend les deux
pieds dans l'eau pour pouvoir récolter
les gobies mais aussi les musées dre le
zooplancton puis les macro invertébrés
une soeur de kate des flèches
donc on essaie de viser des endroits où
il ya des différences dans la topologie
du fonds de l'eau parce que les poissons
aiment se cacher si les poissons restent
dans une surface plate sont à la vue des
prédateurs et c'est là qu'on va mettre
et les filets
je vais laisser les filets dans l'eau
pour au moins deux heures pour maximiser
les chances de capture pour la perchaude
puis l'achigan
pendant ce temps l'équipe se dirige vers
une île du lac saint-françois moyenne
taille qui est capitaine du bateau et
chercheurs stéphanie guerman et
biologiste il procède d'abord à
l'échantillonnage des moules zébrées
parce que le gobie s'en nourrit
d'ailleurs cette moule est également une
espèce envahissante du fleuve saint
laurent et des grands lacs alors les
gars be pour pouvoir les manger
entièrement puis sont capable aussi de
casser la coquille
aussi en les mangeant donc des fois
quand je regarde le res te mens je vois
des trucs des petits mots sur ce qui
reste
ils les moules zébrées filtre beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'eau par jour et ça
filtre tout qu'est-ce que dans l'eau
donc le phytoplancton mais aussi les
containers donc ça fait fuir une
concentration quand même élevé de
contaminants dans les musées très donc
moi je dis tout dépendamment où on
retrouve le gobi et comment se nourrir
est ce qu'ils mangent beaucoup de moules
zébrées et s'apprend voir n'est pas
qu'un peu plus saine et fassent
voulions vous dis
pas qu'on va mal étrangement pas très
pure affection il dépasse à la dernière
minute quand on approche
pour sa soeur qui avait plus rien qui
reste dans le filet
l'équipe ramassent ensuite les macro
invertébrés aquatiques dont le gobie se
nourrit
ouais ça bouge là donc je pense qu'on a
c'est pour vous mon horaire garder ce
domaine
on retourne au bâton pour les filets et
on va aller regarder les flammes à rien
la journée avance il est déjà l'heure
d'aller récolter les prédateurs du gobi
il faut beaucoup
[Musique]
france et la chine toutes des haches une
petite couche je sais travailler le plus
bien de passer pour miner le stress sur
le poisson donc je fais le meilleur que
je peux je suis un peu louche prédateurs
double bios tâche nord
ça a été une journée superbe il fait
beau on entre à payer des copies et des
ashika de nous et bray des invertébrés
dont j'ai tout ce qu'il me faut pour
retourner au laboratoire qui répare m et
analyses
[Musique]
on
le lendemain les macro invertébrés sont
identifiés et compter à la binoculaire
christina dissèque ensuite les poissons
pour étudier ce qu'ils mangent elle
innove en combinant plusieurs analyse le
contenu des estomacs la teneur en acides
gras en isotopes stables et la
contamination au mercure
et trois méthodes de me renseigne de
quelques ils ont mangé sur différentes
périodes de temps par exemple les
estomacs ça me fait vraiment ponctuelles
qu'est ce que le poisson à manger dans
les quelques heures que qui a été
attrapé alors que les autobus table
c'est sur une durée de quelques mois et
les assez grasse et quelques semaines
elle conserve les tubes digestifs et les
muscles au congélateur pour de futures
analyses après plusieurs mois de travail
voici ses résultats
alors qu'est ce que je peux conclure
jusqu'à présent avec mes résultats c'est
que oui le devis à taches noires il ya
une attaque sur la chaîne alimentaire du
clos saint laurent par contre son impact
va dépendre de où on le retrouve ce que
je peux voir ce que t'en lac
saint-françois son impact est pas
vraiment très élevé son rôle prêtre un
peu comparable à d'autres natifs de la
région au niveau du mercure au niveau de
sa valeur nutritionnelle alors que dans
lac-saint-louis l'oeil devient un
vecteur de contenant et devient une
proie pas très nutritive pour les
poissons pibor
les conditions environnementales des
deux lacs diffère ce qui modifie les
quantités d'acides gras et de mercure
disponible dans l'environnement
je trouve ça vraiment intéressant de
pouvoir mettre en lumière que se lier la
honte le gobie la moule zébrée eh bien
ils policiers importante dans certains
habitats comparé à d'autres même si
l'humain ne mange pas de gobi et taches
noires nous consommons certains de ces
prédateurs donc voyais conscient que
on peut pêcher l'achigan ou le doré par
contre peut-être dans certains endroits
leur concentration à mercure va être
plus élevé que la normale à cause du
lien avec du comique
comme le gobie à taches noires et quand
même une espèce envahissante
la consigne demeure de ne pas le
remettre à l'eau
[Musique]